a julia le tomó 20 minutos darse cuenta
de que su tina de hidromasaje tenía una
fuga cuando él se dio cuenta
abrió el drenaje de la tina y el agua
restante salió en 40 minutos la razón a
la cual el agua de la tina se drenó en
galones por minuto se muestra abajo
cuántos galones de agua había en la tina
antes de que empezara a fugarse veamos
qué es lo que tenemos por acá nos dan
una gráfica de galones por minuto contra
tiempo y lo que vemos aquí esta línea
azul es la razón a la cual el agua de la
tina se drenó así es que en el minuto
cero el agua aún no drenaba de la tina
pero a medida que pasó el tiempo empezó
el agua drenar y no tan sólo eso aumentó
el ritmo al cual drenaba así es que a
los diez minutos de estar en la tina el
agua drena va a razón de un galón por
minuto mientras que a los veinte minutos
de estar en la tina el agua ya de
navarra son de dos galones por minuto y
en ese momento se da cuenta y abre el
drenaje me parece que ya quería terminar
con su baño así es que
drenaje y el agua empieza a fluir a una
tasa mayor a 20 galones por minuto pero
esa tasa decrece podríamos pensar en la
física de esto quizás al abrir el
drenaje baja la presión y decrece la
tasa sin embargo no me voy a meter en la
física de esto vamos a tomar como válida
esta gráfica de tal manera que la tasa a
la cual el agua fluye decrece hasta
llegar al minuto 60 por lo que 40
minutos después de que abrió el drenaje
y 60 minutos de que inició su baño
latina se vació completamente dado eso
como calculamos cuántos galones de agua
había en la tina antes de que empezara a
fugarse te invito a que le pongas pausa
al vídeo e intentes hacerlo por tu
cuenta antes de que lo hagamos juntos
bien contestar la pregunta cuántos
galones de agua bien la tina antes de
que empezara a fugarse es lo mismo que
contestar la pregunta cuánta agua se
drenó así es que esta pregunta equivale
a cuánta agua cuánta agua
bueno y para responder a esto podemos
considerar lo que sabíamos antes de que
aprendiéramos cálculo si tenemos algo
que ocurre una tasa fija digamos que
esto es galones por minuto
supongamos que estamos en el mismo
contexto así es que este sería el tiempo
en minutos que sucede entonces cuando el
flujo está drenando a una tasa constante
si lo que deseamos saber es cuál es la
cantidad total de líquido que se drena
en cierto intervalo de tiempo como este
que tenemos aquí el cual podemos llamar
del tate simplemente tenemos que
multiplicar la tasa a la cual está
fluyendo el líquido que sería esta
altura que tenemos aquí que voy a marcar
de color naranja decíamos entonces que
simplemente hay que multiplicar esta
tasa por el intervalo de tiempo
transcurrido y esto básicamente lo que
nos está dando es el área bajo la curva
sobre el intervalo el área bajo la curva
sobre ese intervalo y esta área nos va a
indicar la cantidad total en galones de
líquido que serenó durante ese intervalo
y esto también aplica aunque no sea una
tasa constante
y tuviéramos por ejemplo una taza que se
ve más o menos así como hemos visto en
otros vídeos como te mostrado podemos
calcular la cantidad total de líquido
que se drenó sobre cierto intervalo de
tiempo como este que tenemos aquí
básicamente obteniendo el área bajo la
curva calculando el área bajo la curva
sobre dicho intervalo y las unidades
concuerdan si multiplicamos galones por
minuto por minutos
entonces las unidades de esta área son
galones las unidades de esta área son
talones otra manera de ver esto es como
calculamos el área de este trapezoide
que tenemos acá para el área el
trapezoide encontramos la altura
promedio que va a ser el promedio de las
alturas al inicio y al final del
trapecio de calculamos el promedio entre
esas alturas y esto funciona para una
línea como esta si tomamos esta altura
promedio y la multiplicamos la
multiplicamos por el cambio en el tiempo
de hecho vamos a obtener vamos a
calcular
y así es que la otra manera de ver esto
es que estamos tomando la tasa promedio
sobre el intervalo la estamos
multiplicando por la longitud del
intervalo y eso nos va a dar la cantidad
total en galones así es que tenemos que
aplicar esa idea que literalmente
calcular el área bajo la curva sobre
todo el intervalo desde que el agua
empezó a fugarse o a drenar entre el
minuto cero y el minuto 60
así es que va a ser esta área esta área
que estoy dibujando en magenta más toda
esta área que se encuentra debajo de
esta sección y para hacer el cálculo
vamos a dividir esta área en dos
regiones tenemos esta región triangular
aquí arriba podríamos haber considerado
que las regiones un trapecio de pero la
vamos a dividir en un triángulo y en un
rectángulo así es que también tenemos
esta región de aquí que estoy iluminando
en verde
así es que cuál es el área total aquí
tenemos 20 galones por minuto tenemos 20
no 20 minutos de hecho tenemos 20
minutos que vamos a multiplicar
por 2 galones por minuto y eso lo vamos
a multiplicar por un medio pues estamos
calculando el área de este triángulo y
esto nos va a dar esto es igual a 20 por
240 entre 220 galones vemos que las
unidades son las adecuadas así es que
eso corresponde básicamente a lo que se
drenó durante los primeros 20 minutos
ahora esta área en verde va a ser 40
minutos que multiplica a 10 galones por
minuto 10 galones de hecho no voy a
considerar las unidades lo único que
requiere es calcular el área así es que
va a ser 40 por 10 lo cual es igual a
400 y eso él va a sumar el área de este
triángulo en azul que tiene una base de
40 por la altura que es 20 menos 10 10 y
por un medio porque es un triángulo así
es que es 40 por 10 y por un medio esto
nos da igual a 200 y ahora sumamos estas
tres cantidades que es el valor de las
tres áreas para obtener 400 más 200 600
20 620 620 galones que es la cantidad
total de agua que se drenó o la cantidad
de agua que había en la tina de
hidromasaje antes de que empezara a
fugarse esta es una gran cantidad para
una tina normal pero esta podría ser un
jacuzzi o algo así